[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag l'émission
politique d arte france comme tous les
week-ends on débat avec nos
contributeurs des grands sujets de
l'actualité politique de la semaine
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec lydia
guirous ce essayiste et membre du bureau
politique les républicains face à vous
aurélie gros conseillère régionale
d'ile-de-france et présidente la france
vraiment invitée sur ce plateau
également guettant du soc est membre du
conseil national du rassemblement
national et jean philippe tanguy porte
parole debout la france merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
et c'est à la une cette semaine regarder
l'appel de nicolas dupont aignan à
l'union des patriotes en france cette
semaine lors de la présentation de ses
voeux à la presse le président de debout
la france a émis l'idée d'organiser une
grande primaire l'ancien candidat à
l'elysée a demandé à toutes les
personnalités politiques de l'opposition
républicaine et patriotes de s'unir pour
faire front commun contre emmanuel
macron à la prochaine élection
présidentielle en 2022 péter de 2022 ont
tout à gagner
mais pour gagner ce n'est pas à emmanuel
macron et à son système de choisir son
adversaire
voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui nous avons
proposé une primaire pour la france ce
n'est pas un parti politique avec
quelques milliers d'adhérents de définir
qui sera ce candidat
c'est à des millions d'électeurs et
grâce à cette primaire il y aura un
candidat unique dès le premier tour qui
sera en position de force
jean philippe tanguy l'initiative n'est
pas nouvelle cet appel à à unir l les
droites en l'occurrence pourquoi
pourquoi celle-ci aujourd'hui parce que
la situation est dramatique nous avons
un pays qui à feu et à sang depuis
maintenant plus d'un an
emmanuel macron et paradoxalement
incapable de
sauver la situation de manière
républicaine et politique
mais paradoxalement les européennes ont
montré qu'il gardait malheureusement une
vraie base dans le pays
une base qu'il entretient avec cynisme
qu'il entretient par un certain nombre
de stratagèmes vieux comme le monde mais
qui malheureusement fonctionne bien et
en face on a une opposition qui soit est
apathique je pense aux républicains mais
ils ont à battre à essoyes est persuadé
que la nature va lui offrir le pouvoir
tout seul or nous voyons un scénario que
souhaite le président de la république a
mené le maquereau de toute évidence il
entretient on l'a vu aux européennes et
on ne veut pas que emmanuel macron
choisisse son terrain de bataille et son
adversaire on ne veut pas que le
scénario se répète puisque c'est celui
qu'il veut et moi ils sont que j'ai fait
saint cyr l'école militaire la première
chose qu'on apprend à stratégie
militaire c'est de ne jamais aller sur
le terrain choisi par l'adversaire
jamais alors justement on vous dit le
terrain de l'adversaire cet adversaire
c'est évidemment marine le pen qui a
fait sa déclaration comme candidate à
l'élection présidentielle peut être cela
at-il précipité le calendrier écouter
marine le pen dans la situation que
connaît le pays
ce ballet un peu puéril et très convenu
des ambitions et des égos laisse parfois
perplexe
la france n'a je le crois ni le temps ni
les moyens
c'est pourquoi j'ai tenu très vite à
vous épargner les faux semblants les
déclarations demi teinte les postures
emprunter et puis c'est dans mon
caractère d'être franche et directe car
c'est je crois fondamentalement une
marque de respect pour vous de ne pas
vous cacher ni mes intentions ni mes
objectifs ni les moyens que je me donne
pour les atteindre
c'est donc très tôt sans pour autant
totalement préjuger de la décision qui
appartient au congrès de notre mouvement
qui aura lieu en 2021 que j'ai fait part
de ma volonté de préparer la
présidentielle
voilà donc une déclaration un peu
précoce en guettant du saut c'est ce qui
a peut-être seulement la dir faits réels
des affaires ça après les municipales et
le voilà voilà
à l'orgue et ont dû social le
rassemblement national a déjà envoyé une
fin de non recevoir à la main tendue de
nicolas dupont aignan où est ce que léo
est ce que cette union des droites en
l'occurrence reste possible alors union
des droites juste pour clarifier un peu
le débat qu'on aura l'occasion de
revenir ensuite sur les différents
termes qu'ont utilisés les raisons pour
lesquelles ils utilisent ou les
utilisent pas l'ignorer atriale en
l'occurrence salut je pousse je préfère
je préfère ce qu'ils sont que le
rassemblement national ne milite pas
pour une union dès droite la droite
n'existe plus les n'existe plus c'était
en effet un clivage qui pouvaient
exister encore 5 10 ans mais aujourd'hui
il est complètement effacée en parlait
d'ailleurs s'il a réellement existé donc
donc non en fait sur sur la question de
nicolas dupont aignan de la primaire
nous sommes évidemment pas opposé à
l'idée de travailler ensemble c'est
quelque chose qu'on avait déjà fait dans
le cadre de l'entre-deux tours de
l'élection présidentielle de 2017
ce sur quoi nous sommes opposés c'est
seulement la question de la primaire on
a bien vu tous les partis politiques qui
ont mené des primaires ont été facile de
l'échiquier politique français du
paysage politique français
c'était le cas du parti socialiste
c'était le cas également de l'ump depuis
les républicains dont claude à cannes
gagné sa présidence alors 2010 et après
ils l'ont refait ils ont eu benoît hamon
ils ont fini à 6 % donc abandonné il n'y
aurait pas que la forme est abrogé la
kespa que la primaire soit la solution
est d'ailleurs nicolas dupont aignan
lui-même le disait il il affirmé qu' à
l'arrière et un dîner de cons à l'époque
c'est ce qu'il en disait ce qu'il en
pense et je ne retrouve pas très bien
l'esprit gaullien où l'eau l'héritage
gaulliste du code et ayant horreur
revendique très verni en ce processus
veux parler de ce qu'on leur parle et
nicolas dupont aignan d'ailleurs on a on
a on a effectivement ces déclarations à
l'époque oui oui critiqué
la primaire moi j'ai toujours dit que la
primaire c'était un dîner de cons
d'ailleurs ils vont s'entretuer comme
des crocodiles dans un marigot les
primaires à droite comme à gauche c'est
allez je te permettent expo à lewaï rosé
à dîner de cons c'est à dire que le
programme fixé c'est toujours le même et
on amuse la galerie pendant plusieurs
mois à choisir la personnalité qui va
appliquer un mauvais programme
alors la question des primaires
effectivement fait débat lydia guirous
on a vécu d'ailleurs une primaire
mouvementée à droite on s'en souvient en
2016 entre jean-françois copé et
françois fillon sa présidence du parti
oui pour la présidence du parti d'un
imprimeur et ensuite il ya eu la
primaire à droite où on a vu nicolas
sarkozy d'ailleurs parmi tous les tous
ces anciens ministres quasiment qu'est
ce que est ce que c'est la bonne
solution finalement d'organismes je suis
pas favorable à la primaire je trouve
que ça apporte de la division de manière
artificielle au sein des partis et ça ne
permet pas forcément de toujours sa ré
émerger le meilleur c'est mauvaise idée
qui a été importée des états unis et
puis ensuite qu'on a voulu copier de la
gauche donc sur la question des
primaires moi je n'y suis pas favorable
l'idée de nicolas dupont aignan
finalement c'est tenter d'essayer de
faire parler de lui encore et c'est vrai
que nicolas dupont aignan c'est un coup
de com oui coller les atteindre il est
très souvent habitué aux coupes comme et
je suis certaine que l'année prochaine
ou pendant la présidentielle
il quittera un plateau de télévision
comme il l'a fait très régulièrement
pour faire parler de lui donc je pense
que cette idée n'ira pas bien loin
d'autant plus qu' il parle d' opposition
républicaine ça veut dire qu'on doit
considérer que les partis de gauche
doivent aussi participer à cette
primaire est parti patriote a priori que
par l'opposition républicaine et aider
et des patriotes dont compte le clair
sur l'opposition républicaine moi j mais
également les partis de gauche
alors bon je pense que ça va pas aller
très loin
d'autant plus que nicolas dupont aignan
voulait être le premier ministre de
marine le pen
pourquoi n'a pas tim été jusqu'au bout
de sa démarche pour être dans le parti
de marine le pen
travailler avec marine le pen
être je sais pas le numéro 2 ou faire
alors une primaire en interne
moi j'ai l'impression que la gloire des
lions n'est pas du parti des manuels
macro nicolas dupont aignan moi j'ai
l'impression que quelque part s'il a du
talent il se gâche il se gâche pour des
coups de com régulièrement et pour être
toujours le numéro un dans un parti
politique qui est une cabine
téléphonique
c'est patrick artus havas d'améliorer le
savez c'est une réalité et chantôme
avait apporté peut-être un petit peu
plus affectées sont égaux son ego
l'amène à faire au cas où hugo allard
tous des courbes où la france est une
cabine téléphonique qui qui ne va pas
bien loin et il n'est toujours dans le
coup de com sans four véritablement
voudriez pas dire ça mais vous savez aux
européennes même si nous oui bien sûr
mais vous devriez pas vous répondre
parce que tout simplement les ego aucun
français ne croient que les hommes
politiques n'ont pas d'égaux ça sert à
rien de dire que certains vont savoir le
mettre de côté
auparavant c'est franchement à droite
s'il ya bien un truc qui qui est
constant c'est bien les ego mais au delà
la guerre aux europe est absolument
besoin d'en parler et aux européennes
madame et déroute aux européennes vous
savez il ya un rapport de 1 à 2 entre
nous donc si vous appelez une cabine
téléphonique vous êtes une plus grosse
cabine téléphonique
vous allez on était qu'on était un
accident de parcours et on sait que la
polarisation qu'elle est mise en place
par emmanuel doreau et devantures des
conseils croire emmanuel macron et la
république en marche soit le
rassemblement national qui est l'idiot
utile de la gauche depuis des années et
depuis que ce fameux piège de mitterrand
je trouve que c'est extrêmement
dangereux et moi je crois que notamment
à l'occasion des municipales la droite
républicaine saura montrer qu'elle
existe encore dans le pays qu'elles un
vrai ancrage territorial et des élus de
qualité cela excusez-moi jours et qu'on
est là la réaction d'aurélie gros cette
proposition ce qui pour nous devions
cola dupont aignan cette main tendue
c'est pas nouveau il ya eu déjà des
tentatives qui n'ont pas forcément
réussi jusqu'à présent est ce que joue
aurélie gros qui avait été au sein des
républicains
on est sorti que pensez vous de cette
union des droites je l'appelle ainsi
pour plus de lisibilité
je nous donne je trouve assez pathétique
de la part de ces deux futurs candidats
aux présidentielles d'instrumentaliser
les élections municipales pour faire
parler d'eux et pour mettre en avant en
fin de compte leur candidat aux
municipales
je pense que les français n'en ont pas
besoin je pense que l'élection
présidentielle est bien plus tard après
concernant l'union des droites vous
m'excuserez pour être plutôt à droite
puisque je suis issu à l'origine des
républicains même si j'en suis sorti
j'ai des valeurs de droite j'ai des
valeurs gaullistes vraiment on extrait
le téléspectateur vous êtes plus proche
de valérie pécresse aux jeunes ont alors
la france vraiment pas du tout alors la
france vraiment c'est un mouvement
citoyen qui a été monté il ya deux ans
et demi de concertation citoyenne qui
réunit toutes les forces vives qui
veulent échanger sur les grands sujets
de société c'est totalement non partisan
ça va de personnel de citoyens qui sont
plutôt à gauche jusqu'à des citoyens à
droite
et justement ils échangent sur des
grandes politiques publiques pour
trouver des citoyens des solutions de
terrain ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence
citoyenne et politique vous soliver
proche devenir moi personnellement
politiquement je suis dans la majorité
2 valérie pécresse ce que j'assume très
bien c'était une personne qui fait de la
politique par la preuve ce qu'attendent
les français aujourd'hui clairement
cette main tendue et et cette
instrumentalisation de des élections
municipales de parler des élections
présidentielles à ce moment précis de
faire un appel à la droite qui a essayé
de faire marion maréchal-le pen
au passage c'est à dire que nicolas
dupont aignan elle a ouvert le goal
derrière marine le pen
je crois que clairement au vu des
avancées qui l'avait fait aux dernières
présidentielles il devrait aller
directement avec marine le pen
les programmes sont totalement
différents je vois pas en quoi il
l'appelle
les gens de droite ya des gens de chez
les l'air qui veulent partir chez
monsieur du conte aignan ou chez marine
le pen ils peuvent y aller je veux dire
abandonnez y en a aussi qui sont partis
seuls emmanuel macouin il y en a
d'autres qui sont parties nulles pas ce
que je veux dire à un moment donné je
trouve que ces déclarations m pour nous
il ya ou même d'un flou dans les
municipales et il ya une élection qui
est très importante aujourd'hui c'est
les municipales et je crois qu'il faut
laisser les candidats faire leur
campagne campagne de poule et qu'est-ce
que ça mais que masqueront rom et de la
politique
au milieu de tout ça de la politique
nationale avec des stratégies pour
monter un soi disant grand parti de la
droite des patriotes comme si nous on
n'était pas patriote il ya les patriotes
et il ya les autres
comme le disait même règle à guy roux ce
à un moment donné je veux dire bassement
là où vrai ça aussi au ps il ya des gens
au ps qui sont 400 ans adrien ça serait
bien sûr qu'ils sont de l'opposition
mails macron cirque c'est encore un coup
pour dire emmanuel macron on va le maire
s'est en tout cas côté on va main contre
magna ne m'a pas mal ça n'a aucun sens
il faut appeler aussi le psg reçoit je
me cale pas loin des batailles
les forces politiques aujourd'hui à part
le rassemblement national ne fait pas le
poids au vu des derniers résultats aux
élections mais également aussi qu'ils
n'avaient pas forcément les bons
candidats ou que certains candidats ont
été empêchés à certaines élections
présidentielles et qu'à un moment donné
les parties ont aussi besoin de ce
français à l'arrêt revoir leur leur
logiciel de méthodes vis-à-vis de leurs
militants c'est normal que les partis
évolué vu que la société évolue au
quotidien je dire c'est on est dans une
nouvelle société avec une nouvelle forme
de démocratie rien qu'avec les réseaux
sociaux c'est normal qu'aujourd'hui les
partis politiques à un moment donné
revoient leurs logiciels alors il revoir
les partis politiques la gauche la
droite a priori elle n'a plus bonne
presse en ce moment on l'a vu aux
dernières élections
le clivage gauche-droite existe-t-il
encore jean philippe tanguy a priori non
selon vous mais c'est plus compliqué
parce que l'un n'empêche pas l'autre je
veux dire je reviens sur l'histoire du
dîner de cons parce que c'est comme
importante pouvoir répondre à ça serra
contexte c'est pas les primaires en
général qui sont internés des primaires
qui avaient été derrière les maires
effet des républicains c'était quoi le
problème parce que nous on vient des
républicains beaucoup on voulait pas y
retourner à l'occasion cette primaire et
ça répond à la question de me dire où
sur la gauche c'est que les candidats
s'engagent à se soutenir mutuellement
donc monsieur mélenchon va pas soutenir
monsieur dupont-aignan sa place à mme le
pen collective
on se rassemble sur un programme pour
essayer de gagner et créer l'alternance
mais s'il veut attendre et moi et
gouverner seul dans la durée je tenais
on n'ira pas bien la balle et la
droiture et la régie ville atteint son
plafond de verre mais normal en
déménageant de vers la droite
c'est un plancher de verre veux dire
elle est à 35 % en 2007 et mais
maintenant vous nous donner des leçons
êtes à 8 donc excusé nounou certes n'a
pas fait une grosse performance mais les
européennes ne représentent leurs
clients madame giroux ce jeu vous
agresse pas là dessus mais a toujours
été du goût des je vous dis des faits ça
fait 13 ans que la droite se déchire et
ne gagne plus d'élections alors vous
pouvez dire à chaque fois c'est un
accident c'est pas nous c'est la faute
du monde entier sont de l'organisation
la droite nous avons fait diagnostiquer
on vous dit que il faut se rassembler et
il faut que chacun puisse engager mais
sur un programme qui est cohérent
pourquoi c'est un dîner de cons parce
que monsieur dupont aignan ne pouvait
pas soutenir monsieur juppé c'est
impossible donc tout le monde se réunit
et dit oui bon on n'est pas d'accord on
est d'accord sur rien puisque entre
monsieur juppé et monsieur fillon dire
en fait ils soignent s'opposer
et semblant de s'opposer et au final ils
disent on est d'accord c'est aussi la
raison de l'échec de la gauche en
revanche monsieur hollande ou à mme
aubry il était d'accord donc une
primaire delà du sens n'a de sens que si
les candidats qui y participent sont
cohérents sur leurs programmes et 100
gagne sincèrement à se soutenir l'un
c'est pour ça qu'il dirige chacun pense
de la même manière et à 22,16 lors ces
crimes violents d'une nuance sa n'a pas
réalisé qu'ici c'est ça le blé pas pour
cible annuelle s'il y avait autant les
candidats et c'est pour l'instant d'en
parler des meilleurs sur quel sur quel
projet concrètement cette union des
patriotes peut se peut se former si vous
voulez c'est un projet qui est
complètement à l'inversé de ce qui est
menée aujourd'hui par emmanuel macron et
d'ailleurs c'était une remarque que je
tenais à vous faire un peu avant tout si
ce que vous dites c'est emmanuel macron
qui a mis un peu comme ça spontanément
sur une bonne idée à marine le pen en
face de lui non c'est pas emmanuel
macron c'est les français le soir du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle
c'est eux qui ont décidé de placer
marine le pen alors en seconde position
pour se confronter à emmanuel macron
ensuite au second tour c'est encore eux
qui ont décidé de mettre la liste portée
par à jordan bardella est appuyé par un
marine le pen en tête des élections
européennes dernière manque donc tout ça
c'est les français qui décide de la même
manière que vous accusez finalement
l'entrée en campagne de marine le pen
dans la préparation du moins de la
campagne présidentielle de 2000 22,2
d'essayer de nationaliser la campagne
des municipales
mais les français ne sont pas idiots et
saveurs réfléchir par eux-mêmes s'ils
veulent voter pour pénaliser pour mettre
un carton rouge à emmanuel macron eh
bien ils le feront en votant pour les
listes du rassemblement national
s'ils veulent voter pour des sujets
locaux qui consiste à se préoccuper de
leur quotidien au plus près de chez eux
eh bien ils le feront pour les listes et
plus à même de s'occuper d'eux donc ils
peuvent réfléchir entièrement par
romaine et ce n'est pas évidemment en
regardant ce que ce qui passe à la télé
qui se fondent et des idées ou des
projets politiques
alors on débat évidemment si ici par
exemple la droite en tout cas le rêve de
nicolas dupont aignan aujourd'hui se
réaliser
aux dernières élections présidentielles
en 2017 si la droite c'était une il
aurait fait 47,2 % des voix au premier
tour de l'élection et elle aurait fait
aux européennes elle aurait obtenu 37,8
pour cent des voix voilà on à
l'infographie à l'écran évidemment c'est
une projection fiction puisque les
reports de voix ne sont pas automatiques
on le sait bien
néanmoins il y à des valeurs communes
que défendent en tout cas tout c'est
parti patriote
quelles sont-elles jean philippe tanguy
et autour de quel projet justement c'est
droite pourraient s'unir selon selon le
président de debout la france
c'est une idée très simple qui peut
peut-être vous paraître naïve mais qui
face à emmanuel macron n'est pas si naïf
c'est déjà l'amour de la france l'amour
de la france dans sa culture la défense
de ses intérêts par exemple pas
dilapider les entreprises nationales
alstom technip au vent c'est défendre
une diplomatie française on voit avec
l'iran que monsieur mac on s'est
précipité pour défendre les états unis
qui venait d'assassiner général iranien
sans même avoir le début de la fin d'une
enquête pour avant se prononcer quand
même ce sont des choses graves
les exemples sont très nombreux donc
l'amour de la france est très important
le respect des français le respect de la
démocratie
aussi sans doute une nouvelle forme de
démocratie plus directe et c'est enfin
le plus important le respect du travail
c'est quand même la valeur fondamentale
des partis de droite en général mais
aussi des partis populaires qu'on ne
puisse plus vivre de son travail en
france est un scandale
le fondamental et je pense que tous nos
parties pourraient se mettre d'accord
sur un vrai une vraie façon de mieux
rémunérer le travail des nouvelles
formes
la participation dans les entreprises le
capitalisme populaire est en fait la
primaire pourquoi est ce qu'on veut une
premère aussi c'est que je pense et
c'est ce que monsieur dupont-aignan a
tiré comme leçon de 2017 que par rapport
à maquereau qui incarne une certaine
nouveauté il faut en mettre une envie
une envie de france du changement en
tout cas l envie de changement pas de
réussir arty traditionnel absolument en
face nous on est quand même des partis à
ses anciens et qui avons surtout un
programme qui commence à peu à s'user et
je crois que on est tellement parfois
sur de nous qu'on se rend pas compte que
notre programme c'est un peu s'user et
la primaire comme l'avait fait monsieur
montebourg avec hollande avec la
démondialisation il avait apporté des
nouvelles idées à cette famille
politique et monsieur hollande avait pu
s'en saisir
et faire une surprise donc il faut pas
les faits tout le monde parle de
personnes mais mon crois que monsieur
dupont-aignan veut la place mais ça n'a
aucun sens puisque lorsque sa fille
monsieur dupont-aignan limpide gère la
primaire une guerre d'égos ensuite que
les chefs vont vouloir en fait ce ne
seront pas forcément la crainte est bien
sûr que je comprends je comprends que ça
je comprends mais personne ne voit
souffler la grosse si mal
la primaire c'est quoi c'est que notre
camp est en dépression collective les
aux européennes nord aux européennes le
camp n'a pas fait un bon score je suis
désolé on vous l'avez dit vous-même 47%
en 2010 7 37% en 2019
on perd 10 points c'était déjà pas
brillant avant dernier de la droite unie
oui bien sûr de ce qu'on pourrait
rassembler il se passe dans un contexte
notre camp n'est pas je suis enfin
clarifier les mages et oui bon je vous
ai le souffle je suis de droite et je
dois vous avez public n je suis contre
l'union des droites
je pense que quand on est qu'au liste on
peut pas et personne n'a pas réglé on
peut pas on peut pas se rassembler avec
le front national qui a repeint la
façade s appelle le rassemblement
national voilà il ya un peu d'histoire
faut savoir se souvenir et et d'ailleurs
mais qu'est ce que c'est que le
rassemblement national aujourd'hui est
ce que ce sont des libéraux ou est ce
que ce sont des gens qui qui qui ont le
les cônes le la vision économique de
mélenchon et les manifestations de la
cgt
moi je voudrais comprendre s'il avait
quelques mélange lisse conques ont
rejoint lourd
la réforme nous avons aussi des membres
de la droite populaire thierry mariani
jean paul garraud qui on reçoit le
rassemblement national où l'américain
qui ont fait alliance avec le
rassemblement national dans des
municipalités à lui à noter si j'oublie
leur leur valeur s'ils n'ont pas de
colonne vertébrale si leur volonté c'est
d'être exclusivement élus c'est leur
choix mais je pense que quand on est
gaulliste quand on a un petit peu de
colonne vertébrale on ne fait pas ce
choix là dans les histoires excusez-moi
lui-même vous avez fait alliance avec
l'udf et le rpr gaulliste c'est lié avec
l'udf l'udf historiquement c'est le
parti le plus anti gaulliste de
l'histoire de la saq et république il
n'y a pas la même histoire l'unifab à
vous devrez disposer de droits des
migrants nous qui sépare les avoirs non
l'udf il est pas du rennais a les mêmes
freins à la base l'udf c'est le
recyclage vous savez madame migros que
l'udf à la basse et le recyclage de tous
les membres de ça donc c'est trop facile
dans les gaullistes quand ça nous a
rendu ce 2 le véritable problème si vous
voulez c'est de savoir quelle est notre
objectif aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est
évidemment de redresser la situation
dans notre pays que ce soit pour faire
face justement à la crise économique et
social dans lequel le gouvernement est
en train de plonger l'ensemble des
français que ce soit pour faire face à
la crise et la submersion migratoire
parce que encore dernièrement les
chiffres de demandeurs d'asile ont
explosé littéralement dans notre pays
mais ça évidemment on l'évacué on en
parle peu donc il ya un moment donné il
faut aussi se ressaisir se dire il ya
une urgence
il est très clairement une urgence est
d'arriver au pouvoir pour changer de
politique
on peut pas continuer si vous voulez à
chacun offert un peu notre course dans
nos propres couloir et qui risquent de
se rassembler pour former cette majorité
qui apportera l'alternative politique à
la tête de l'état je vous propose mais
dans ma mère me désole reprise à plat
d'accord on est bien à sa gloire
non mais t'es sûr sur la raison vient du
fait qu'en quand marine le pen propose
qu'on laisse la retraite à combattre la
retraite à 60 ans vous savez très bien
ce que ça veut dire non mais savait très
bien ce que ça veut dire et le redire à
tous
grant et ça veut dire quoi c'est votre
question c'est une question de programme
rien que la question de mon programme à
votre lieu entre le programme dlr est le
programme du front national pour trouver
le lien au delà de ce qu'a dit madame me
guy roux ça avec lesquels je suis
totalement d'accord se dire que
l'histoire du parti du front national a
dû ronger décoré jours alors cela est la
ligne rouge existe toujours et ses
lecteurs existait aussi ses grands et
bilal savez pourquoi mais c'est pour ça
si vous voulez contacter cdc débat de
dire on va s'allier avec la droite ça
n'a absolument aucun sens parce que la
preuve chez les républicains vous avez
de tout vous aviez du moins à l'époque
vous aviez thierry mariani souverainiste
attacher une droite populaire et qui est
maintenant nous a rejoint l exacte et
mariah carey bien sûr vous aviez vous
aviez au même moment à l'époque d alain
juppé des personnes qui sont aujourd'hui
au gouvernement d' emmanuel macron donc
c'était les républicains qui ont repris
en vérifier le statut dans l'équipe
dirigeante et républicains visant à
aller vers le rassemblement national
s'est amené à je pense qu'il n'ya pas
y'a pas grand monde à part des gens qui
sont peut-être en fin de carrière et qui
ont besoin d'être recyclés et d'avoir un
mandat solide en marche océans dans la
manche sinon au sein des républicains
vous avez des centristes moi je
travaille que dernier un bête qui est
plutôt centriste et julien aubert klepto
souverainiste vous avez des libéraux je
vais pas y avait voilà virginie calmels
qui présentait plutôt le courant libéral
avec d'autres vous avez des républicains
attachés à la laïcité la lutte contre le
communautarisme comme moi et comme tant
d'autres vous avez tous ces courants au
sein des républicains et la cohérence ce
qu'on a on a des valeurs communes est en
avance pour pouvoir apporter aux
français un projet est une véritable
alternance et on est sur le travail de
fond
moi je pense que vous avez des gens qui
sont qualifiés des gens de qualité des
gens qui ont de l'expérience et on voit
bien ce que c'est que mettre des gens
qui n'ont pas d'expérience au parlement
ou au gouvernement et la république en
bas on voit que la france ça patine ça
va mal que les députés sont parfois plus
tôt des godillots plutôt que des députés
qui travaillent et qui est qu'ils savent
faire la loi et donc je ne serai plus
blanc lorsque
les républicains représente une
alternative qui est certes en
construction parce qu'elle a vécu des
moments difficiles mais qui est
l'alternative la plus sérieuse
aujourd'hui en france trains restés avec
nous on continue ce débat sur la droite
conservatrice et patriotes en france
alors que le président de debout la
france a lancé un appel à une grande
primaire pour 2022
nicolas sarkozy lui était l'invité
d'honneur de la cérémonie des voeux des
républicains l'ancien président est il
un atout ou un boulet pour les
conservateurs on en parle dans quelques
minutes à tout
[Musique]
la crise de 2008 arrive et à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit que les choses ont été
mal faites
on n'avait aucunement prévu des
scénarios de crise de défaut de paiement
tant qu'on maintient la grèce avec les
mêmes conditions qui ont provoqué cette
crise
vous aurez le même système il serait
plus cohérent qu'elle reprenne son
existence en main monnaie comprise mais
je reprendre saab sa monnaie ne résout
pas tout les tous les problèmes
bien sûr qu'il faut changer les hommes
qui dirigent parce que sinon vous ne
résoudrait rien en sortant de l'euro on
veut en fait forcé la marche du
transformation d'un pays donc
effectivement peut-être que certains
grecs ont envie de voir cette marche de
transformation du fric est sans aucun
doute une grande partie n'ont pas envie
de cette transformation son entrée dans
l'euro est en grande partie responsable
de ce qui lui arrive
[Musique]
la france a été la destination
principale des peintres russes dans la
seconde moitié du 19e siècle
[Musique]
on
repin épauler nord s'est teinte on les
connais pas par leur nom mais on les
connaît par le tableau qu'ils ont fait
nous vivions coupé dessous et très
joyeusement mais nous y travaillons
aussi très sérieusement écrit bogoliubov
dans une école c'est unique mais en même
temps la lumière est très proche de
celle de la russie
chez nous la rivière c'est la volga ici
c'est la mer entre saint louis sergent
tu es si belle et romantique
le vent est aussi intense et puissant
[Musique]
c'est quoi pour vous fils république
éthique
écoutez c'est une république qui se
préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption et est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût de la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employé d'un lieu la
firme pin up fillion la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés ne
comprenait pas le problème lorsqu'il
faisait tous ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques des combines et ccc sans fin
je pense que la population les citoyens
ne réclame pas suffisamment cette
moralisation du citoyen à une doit
reprendre sa place et doit sanctionner
les élus indélicats et doit promouvoir
au contraire ceux qui proposent des
mesures visant à éviter les abus
[Musique]
un pôle it mag la suite avec nos
contributeurs lydia guirous ce aurélie
gros et nos invités gates ont du succès
du rassemblement national et jean
philippe tanguy de debout la france un
boulet nicolas sarkozy pour les
républicains c'est la question de cette
deuxième partie et il a fait salle
comble cette semaine l'ancien président
de la république invité d'honneur de la
cérémonie des voeux républicaine et non
pas des républicains les mots ont un
sens puisque nicolas sarkozy a été
invité à la demande du numéro 2 vlr
guillaume pelletier et celle du maire de
la république en marge de la ligne de
romorantin
la proximité de leur ancien chef avec
emmanuel macron commence à en agacer
plus d'un chez les lr alors que le parti
est en pleine tentative de reconquête
politique
écoutez
[Musique]
j'ai vu deux hommes qui au fond macolin
dans sa vie dans sa circonscription qui
défendront demain des politiques
différentes mais qui savent donner une
réalité à l'idée de la république
là où d'autres l'abyme en essayant
d'allumer partout des feux de la haine
et de la discorde
je peux pas accepter ce spectacle là
parce qu'ils abaissent notre pays et moi
je n'aime qu'une chose c'est ce qui
valorise la france et ses scènes de
violence elle abaisse la france voilà
pour le discours de l'ancien chef de
l'état lydia guirous sont nicolas
sarkozy n'est pas bien clair il est
toujours tiraillé entre la république en
marche enfin emmanuel macron pour qui il
a de l'admiration a priori et son propre
parti il n'a pas pris position
clairement nicolas sarkozy se comporte
comme un ancien président de la
république de manière républicaine donc
y voilà enfin il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
je pense que quand le président de
république lui demande de le représenter
à l'étranger il le fait de s'élancer le
protocole et c'est son rôle il sert à
tuer quand les rails du sultan doman
pour représenter effectivement la france
est maintenant c'est à l'ua n'on
également exactement et dans ce discours
des l'extrait que vous venez de passer
c'était au voeu de guillaume pelletier
le numéro deux des républicains
il déplore les séditieux qui qui
allument des feux dans toute la france
c'est vrai que la france est dans un
état de tension et de violence inouïe
on a l'impression qu'on a pu on n'arrive
plus à dialoguer et donc en républicain
en ancien président de la république
responsable soucieux de l'ordre qui peut
régner en ce moment des faits qualifiés
de l'image de la france voir si dans le
monde
eh bien il alerte et je crois pas qu'il
ait véritablement envie de revenir en
petit nombre réduit il l'a dit j'en ai
discuté avec lui c'est pas son objectif
mais il a voilà la france je vis au
corps il peut pas être indifférent il
n'est pas indifférent à l'avenir de sa
famille politique non plus les
différentes personnalités de sa famille
politique il est toujours présent
toujours disponible pour recevoir pour
donner un
conseils pour pour échanger et je crois
que c'est ce qui le rend attachant
auprès des français c'est une
personnalité à part nicolas sarkozy au
sein du parti certains s'agacent quand
même de 7,1 de cette proximité en tout
cas de nicolas sarkozy les avec dans la
politique partisane mais il est fidèle à
son parti politique et aux personnalités
de son parti politique qui l'a qu'il a
parfois porté haut et les gros votre
sentiment là-dessus est ce que le fait
que nicolas sarkozy
et de la proximité avec emmanuel macron
ça peut nuire justement à renouveau en
tout cas à la reconquête des
républicains ou pas je crois franchement
qu'en tant qu'ancien quelqu'un de la
république il est normal qu'ils
entretiennent les meilleures relations
avec le président de la république
après je pense qu'on fait c'est pas le
cas du tout peu à roland c'est justement
un peu plus il n'y avait pas ils ont
regardé le maintien aux élections
municipales ou clairement sur certains
candidats vous vous retrouvez avec des
candidats qui sont les républicains en
marche modem udi
voilà qui ont toutes les composantes
politiques de droite avec la république
en marche sur la liste je pense que ce
que veut dire nicolas sarkozy par son
message c'est un message d'apaisement
pour essayer de réconcilier les français
on sait très bien que à droite on le
disait en début de débat il y a
plusieurs tendances à droite il ya des
progressistes et il ya des des
traditionalistes bon ce qui est très
bien ce qu'il fait là la diversité delà
d'un simple dure toute la diversité de
la droite
après je pense que c'est la droite votre
droit à celle des républicains que vous
avez quitté pourra se réunir à nouveau
ou pas avec ma conscience je pense que
la droite pour à s'unir à nouveau avec
vraisemblablement un combat commun et un
programme décidé en concertation avec
l'ensemble des composantes de ce parti
après je pense qu'une partie de la
droite effectivement est beaucoup plus
proche des manuels macron qui fait quand
même un programme qui issus en partie du
programme de monsieur fillon et qu'une
autre partie de la droite pourrait
partir rejoindre d'autres partis encore
plus à droite
mais bon d'en faire l'analyse de la moi
je n'étais pas d'accord at il déjà unis
et ailleurs on la belle vous avez des
listes les républicains qui sont alliés
avec les centristes d'hervé morin les
tendances de la droite sont déjà unis et
je pense que il n'ya pas que emmanuel
macron où il aura son nom national il ya
une autre voie après c'est de la
responsabilité des responsables
politiques de droite de rendre leurs
propositions leur programme crédible aux
yeux des français de retrouver une voix
qui porte et il a une âme une agréable
sur voilà qui élabore un leader qui qui
qui voilà qui
la leader par yorick enfin valérie
pécresse a proposé les venu et a essayé
d'insuffler un nouveau courant qui était
libre au sein des républicains ressemble
à un conseil national ont accès à l
avait bien vous avez accepté la création
de livres sans emmener tout à fait
d'accord été volés ressenti du tout
entendu et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'elle a quitté les républicains quand
vous avez une personnalité dans les
queues europolitique la crise et les
républicains parce que à un moment donné
la ligne politique des républicains
n'étaient pas claires elle était claire
mét application ipad et convenait pas de
loin vu de cette 7e droite conservatrice
traditionalistes pour reprendre les gros
les électeurs on voit parler des
électeurs ce qu'ils en aient beaucoup
dans les appareils les électeurs sont
quand même beaucoup aller vers le
rassemblement national lors des
dernières élections quel est selon vous
l'explication est est ce que vous votre
stratégie c'est toujours d'en attirer
davantage et si vous voulez il ya des
électeurs qui de fait viennent vers nous
et qui viennent de tout horizon que ce
soit 2 anciennement la droite ou à vous
mme anciennement la gauche la droite
certainement parce qu'ils retrouvent
dans notre programme dans le programme
du rassemblement national et de marine
le pen est bien un amour delà de la
france un patriotisme
un pouvoir régalien rétabli dans ses
fonctions les déçus de la politique
certainement des déçus de de la
politique avait été menée à l'époque par
nicolas sarkozy évidemment de françois
hollande on en attendait pas tellement
et aujourd'hui encore des manuels macron
qui consiste à laisser les portes
grandes ouvertes de la maison france à
l'immigration et aux quatre vents de la
mondialisation
donc je pense qu'on retrouve en effet
des gens qui viennent plutôt de
l'électorat on va dire de droite sur ces
questions-là retrouver des gens qui
viennent plutôt d'un électorat de gauche
sur les questions sociales économiques
mais aussi lié encore une fois la
question de l'immigration ce que
beaucoup ont découvert aussi le problème
que peut apporter au quotidien les
migrations quand elle est concentrée
dans ses rangs un certain nombre de
quartiers et pourtant nicolas sarkozy
avait il y a quelques années
décomplexés cette droite en parlant de
2,7 de cette droite décomplexée écouter
ce que disait nicolas sarkozy à l'époque
sur ses partisans de la droite qu'ils
n'osaient même pas lire en fête qu'ils
étaient de droite écouter tandis que la
gauche ne cesse d'affirmer sa fierté
d'exister en tant que tel nombre de
responsables de l'opposition considère
comme quasi infamant d'être catalogué à
droite tout en s'abstenant de préciser
ce qu'ils sont ce faisant ils organisent
les conditions de notre défaite
idéologique
avant même l'engagement de la bataille
car enfin pourquoi donc sauvé t-il noble
d'être de gauche
il faudrait t'il s'excuser d'être de
droite c'est vrai qu'avant et cette
droite décomplexée
jean philippe tanguy là et les français
en fait n'osais pas dire qu'ils étaient
de droite ça remonte même à chaud de vol
en ballon tout à l'heure les français je
ne sais pas morte ou câble ce sarkozy il
fait décomplexée sert complexe et tout
de suite au pouvoir puisqu'il a fait
venir monsieur kouchner tout un tas de
ministres de gauche
tant et si bien que monsieur nature oui
bah ça lui a pas réussi et ça n'a
surtout pas réussi à la france mais
au-delà de ça si vous laissez pas un
problème de droite et gauche
c'est un problème une fois de plus
d'amour de la france je suis désolé
effectivement le gaullisme c'est vrai
que le fait de s'assumer un de ses
souliers de droit et nous absolue mais
vous savez vous estimez quand vous avez
des valeurs si vous défendez la sécurité
face aux voyous si vous fermez les
frontières et vous bloquer l'immigration
si vous défendez la terre économique de
la france et la valeur travail de fait
vous êtes dans une famille politique qui
historiquement est celle de la droite
qui n'empêche pas ce que c'est le
général de gaulle 2
s'ouvrir et notamment évidemment aux
classes modestes aux classes populaires
qui font la valeur de ce pays et qui
font la richesse de ce pays
c'est énorme a tiré d'ailleurs nicolas
ce lyonnais et claviculaire mais c'est
vrai nicolas sarkozy a fait une très
bonne campagne en 2007 pourquoi le nier
pourquoi le nid on ne nie pas il a déçu
au pouvoir et je reviens à l'idée des
primaires de la primaire pour la france
sarkozy à l'époque qu'est ce qu'il fait
il arrive à faire une rupture est il
faut être franc moi je suis là je veux
qu'on gagne ou fait pas la fin du cinéma
il arrive à faire une rupture en étant
dans le système depuis 20 ans quand même
assez fort un pur c'est quand même assez
fort face à ségolène royal
et comment il fait ça en faisant une
rénovation en ouvrant les portes les
fenêtres et en faisant un grand
mouvement certes c'était pas une
primaire mais le processus était était
celui ci parce que nicolas dupont aignan
l'affronter à l'époque c'était d'ouvrir
au maximum et ce qui tue notre voie le
temps c'est que nous sommes enfermés sur
nous-mêmes et et moi je suis vraiment à
télé réalité en réalité ce peut penser
que nicolas sarkozy ait gagné la
présidentielle en 2007 parce que l'on va
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des spécialistes
et des observateurs la vie politique
française le disais il était allé un peu
chassés comme on disait à l'époque sur
les haies sur les terres et sur les
thématiques
s'ouvrir c'est ce qu'on pouvait
s'attendre normalement d'un homme de
droite il a semblé les deux thèmes qui
étaient de droite et n'était pas
complexés d'être de droite et il est il
allé dans les médias en assumant d'être
de droite
ce que je ne faisais pas beaucoup de
gens de droite il ya une partie de la
droite qui est une droite honteuse qui
va tergiverser pas utiliser les mots il
ya toujours eu peur du regard des médias
et et nicolas sarkozy n'a pas eu peur de
cela il a assumé d'aller sur
l'immigration il a assumé de sa mission
d'aller chercher les classes populaires
aussi alors évidemment sur un
quinquennat tout ne peut pas être
parfait mais je pense que la crise de
beaucoup ne l'auraient pas gérer comme
nicolas sarkozy a réussi à la gérer et
je crois qu'il faut quand même le
reconnaître et le rappeler parce que
c'est important
nous venons siens pour des problèmes
c'est à dire la question la question de
l'ouverture moi je pense que dans la
manière de gouverner de nicolas sarkozy
il faut lui rendre grâce qui l'a
beaucoup d'audace et il ya des
personnalités qui ont émergé on le doit
uniquement à nicolas sarkozy moi mon
parcours je dois nicolas sarkozy qui m'a
donné ma chance je pense qu'on en a
beaucoup d'autres qui sont comme ça et
c'est ce qui manque aujourd'hui à droite
c'est vrai que les profils sont tous les
mêmes
du coup ça donne moins envie aux
électeurs ils se reconnaissent peut-être
un petit peu moins lorsque
sociologiquement ce sont toujours les
mêmes profils et et nicolas sarkozy
c'est transgresser
ici il sait sortir de la boîte et et m
et aller vers vers des terrains qui sont
pas forcément les terrains les plus
confortables mais qui permettent de
faire émerger des idées de faire émerger
des personnalités et de faire avancer
comme ça le parti ait compris nicolas
sarkozy sait se décomplexer à partir du
moment où il s'agit d'insultés un
français de pauvre con mais par contre
il s'agit bien en 2012 et ont capté la
formation continue c'est pas parce qu on
le fait à l'abri des caméras
chirac je pense qu'un françois
mitterrand ont dû avoir des mots comme
ça qui ont dépassé leurs pensées pas
d'accord il avance qu'il a bien fait ou
pas bien fait comment c'est que le temps
des passages de la seule défaite dans
cette relation encore plus passer un
petit deux tiennent pas pour dire à la
fois là on ne peut pas dire si vous
voulez regarder lui on ne peut pas dire
droite décomplexée à partir du moment où
nicolas sarkozy était certes avant
emmanuel macron le président record de
l'immigration en france c'était un
million d'étrangers sous son seul
quinquennat le gouvernement aidera t
elle dire il a trouvé mieux en mieux
même encore repoussé le record play ce
que cet héritage de la droite
décomplexée est toujours d'actualité
pour vous et migros est ce que la droite
est redevenue une droite avec beaucoup
de nuances un libéral csssm droite c'est
une droite avec beaucoup de nuances mais
je crois qu'aujourd'hui quand clairement
la droite est totalement décomplexé il
ya des grands sujets régaliens qui a
repris la droite de façon plutôt forte
mais tout le monde d'ailleurs une ration
aujourd'hui c'est devenu voilà le sujet
de l'immigration et il tente rien n'a
rien
oui pourquoi prix à l'arrêt faisant par
là que je suis d'accord mais des actes
mais vous pas de relais combien ils sont
mais là et 2006 avant de la seule la
salle louis très maladroit mais ça fait
partie
il ya une partie des débris de la
république en marche qui sont de loin de
droite
donc à un moment donné moi et régionales
non je alors non je ne prépare pas les
régionales rigole vous voyez à d'abdou
n'est pas grave vous pouvez rigoler tout
simplement ce que j'explique que là
c'est que vous votre seul sujet que vous
avez en bouche avec notamment marine le
pen c'est l'immigration c'est d'opposer
mais bien sûr de lui des conditions de
route migratoire vous opposez des
français aux uns aux autres dans le gard
vous n'avez plus belgique en est un
c'est faux pas et poser les français
françois parlant d'immigration mais la
france est quand même une terre
d'accueil
1 on est allé gratter misrata pareil
daniel mach et le débat sur
l'immigration a été mis sur la table par
emmanuelle collas samoa et que mère sa
tante et d'acier dalle moi
personnellement il devance de bosses on
est pas tous mois espère seulement les
polémiques je considère que le débat de
l'immigration n'est pas réservée au
front national ni à debout la france
d'ailleurs ni à la droite ni à emmanuel
macron ni à la gauche c'est un débat de
la france contrairement à ce que vous
racontez vous apparemment vous êtes ceux
qui aiment la france nous apparemment
nous n'aimons pas la france on a bien
compris et il est peu probable
gd à 17 si c'est ce que vous avez sous
entendus moi je pense que la droite
aujourd'hui peut se reconstruire
tout comme la gauche il y a des valeurs
moi clairement et que ce soit dans mon
mouvement ou ailleurs nous avons des
gens de droite nous avons des gens de
gauche
effectivement nous n'avons pas des gens
de l'extrême droite ni de l'extrême
gauche et ça me va très bien comme ça
parce que je pense que la droite comme
l'a fait nicolas sarkozy d'ailleurs dans
son gouvernement avec son ouverture
effectivement dans un gouvernement avec
des personnalités plutôt à gauche était
une bonne chose et moi je salue en tout
cas le quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
qui a su au moins un carnet qui était la
présidence de la république
j'aimerais qu'on n'écoute pas le général
de gaulle en personne en tout cas ce
qu'il à être dit en 1965 et l'a
visiblement il n'y avait pas tellement
de de droite finalement ce mot là même
le général
ne le prenez pas dans ces mots écoutez
le fait que les partisans de droite et
les partisans de gauche déclare que
j'appartiens l'autre côté prouve
précisément ce que je vous dis c'est à
dire que maintenant comme toujours je ne
suis pas d'un côté je ne suis pas de
l'autre je suis pour la france on va
retrouver un petit peu ce que vous
défendez les uns et les autres donc pas
à pas de pas de deux de droite à
proprement parler avec des nuances c'est
ce que défend des lolos président
puisqu'il était à la tête de la france
mais l'amour pour la france est ce que
c'est parce qu'ils vous réunit
finalement les skis ce soir autour de
cette table est absolument moi je
n'accuse pas du tout madame du rousse
pour lequel le sait et beaucoup
d'admiration je ne connaissais pas
madame et qui peut la voir ah oui
effectivement
oui mon admiration pour jean paul aime
la france on sent dernière entraînant
les mélenchonistes et aimablement on
vous annonçait que les gens voilà voilà
quand on s'engage en politique on le
fait pour l'intérêt général non peut se
tromper on peut se tromper on peut
prendre la mauvaise voie
mais la volonté initiale c'est quand
même celle ci fait vrai et d'ailleurs on
manque un peu de vocations il est moins
en moins de chevaux qui veulent sa vie
la france mais juste pour répondre sur
le général de gaulle très court après je
laisse la parole parce que j'ai un peu
abusé le vénérable de gaulle quand il
prononcé ces paroles
il est président de la république
président m'a puis quand vous êtes
président de la république naturellement
vous devez dépasser tout sexuelle
évidemment là et c'est mon rapport avec
me connaître absolument
et ce n'est pas les autres les français
le font c'est pas moi de le faire mais
il ya en nous on parle là debout la
france de la prise du pouvoir s'il est
la prise du pouvoir n'est pas à
l'exercice du pouvoir
la prise de pouvoir vous avez des
partisans avaient des électeurs vous
avez des sympathisants qui vous préfère
par rapport à d'autres candidats et ce
qui est assez intéressant le discours
change soit castellas appelle les
secours
il faut s'atteler à une élection une
élection ça tu gagnes et on à droite on
parle jamais comme on gagne alors on
fait du grand blabla du matin la gauche
il se dit que le manga le schéma des
rassemblements ils savent très bien
faire et que général de gaulle a aussi
été marquée par la résistance par la
seconde guerre mondiale par la guerre
d'algérie
donc je pense que dans son esprit
c'était ce qui aimait la france et ceux
qui ont notamment collaboré ceux qui ont
à qui ont participé à des attentats et à
la division de la france donc cesser de
cette manière là que devaient voir les
choses le général de gaulle il était
marqué par cette histoire là j'ai
l'impression que le général de gaulle
est à la mode puisque c'est l'année de
commémoration évidemment et ernée
d'ailleurs dans son gouvernement
il avait tout le monde mes lives monde
tout le monde se mélange et revend les
allées générale dans tout le monde se
dit gaulliste
est-ce que c'est pas un peu galvaudé
bien sûr il sortait on sortait d'une
guerre avec des dommages incommensurable
pour l'ensemble des français c'était le
président de tous les français
parce que générale ici à incarner cela
tous les partis de droite sont en tout
cas les français ont travaillé en
romandie que le général de gaulle tous
les partis de droite revendique le
général de gaulle oui puisque ça a été
un modèle un modèle pour nous tous donc
effectivement je pense pas que marine le
pen se revendiquent de général de l'oua
l'écouté des dernières années c'est sûr
disait monsieur en campagne électorale
tout perdu dans le même marine le pen et
même peut-être son père pourra se
revendiquer du bon d'accord il a déclaré
lionel beaucoup évidemment beaucoup
d'admiration et pour le général doit
bien sûr régulièrement qu'elle quels
sont selon vous les pour ces municipales
on a vu rachida dati qui pour la
première fois est passé devant benjamin
griveaux à paris notamment
ça veut dire que la droite a encore une
marge justement de pouvoir se relever on
le voit 1 19%
un sondage qui a surpris c'est un
sondage guerrero ce qui a surpris qui
rassure qui récompense aussi sa présence
sur le terrain une ligne claire et voilà
c'est la ville d'aujourd'hui c'est la
clarté de la ligne et puis et puis je
pense que le contexte social les
tensions qui sont très importantes dans
dans le pays et notamment à paris on le
sent beaucoup après les gilet jaune
toutes ces manifestations et le blocage
avec les manifestations et les grèves
contre la réforme des retraites les
parisiens le centre je pense font payer
aussi les représentants du parti de
manuela et en plus il ya la division
entre villani et et griveaux on comprend
pas très bien une personnalité de
benjamin griveaux qui semble ne pas très
bien passé non plus ce que j'allais dire
la séparation des deux candidats la
république en marche profite à rachida
dati après ce que je trouve plutôt
dommage de la part de rachida dati c'est
de limoger des candidats comme le maire
du xvème arrondissement qui a fait ses
preuves et qui bataille des républicains
ont encore une bataille interne qui ne
donne pas le bon exemple en termes de
partir et que ces dits mauvaise image et
ses divisions sont vraiment intenses
regrettable et après sur paris au delà
des sondages je pense qu'il va falloir
attendre le deuxième tour voire le
troisième tour et les alliances qui vont
se faire
merci c'est la fin de ce deuxième débat
c'est l'heure du coup de gueule à
présent
[Musique]
et votre coup de gueule lydia guirous
c'est les propos d' abdallah zekri à sud
radio concernant milla l'adolescente qui
a été harcelés pour avoir critiqué
l'islam délégué général du cfcm dit elle
l'a cherché donc elle assume alors c'est
pitoyable de la peur d'abdel des laze
écrit mais il est pas à sa première à sa
première tentative
millas est une jeune fille qui a 16 ans
chi x euros qui indiquait qu'elle était
lesbienne qui critiquent toutes les
religions et notamment l'islam tel
effort dans sa critique aussi où il faut
le signer alors rien la lys et la
liberté des collections c'est la liberté
d'expression en france on a le droit de
blasphémer de critiquer les religions
ce n'est absolument pas illégal elle a
le droit de le faire est là elle a fait
face à un déferlement de haine de
menaces elle a dû quitter son lycée elle
a dû déménager de manière urgente pour
se mettre à l'abri c'est une jeune fille
qui a 16 ans rappelons le est monsieur
écrit de manière indigne de manière
scandaleuse il les représentants du cfcm
a dit qu'elle l'avait cherchée qu'elle
devait assumer les conséquences de ses
de ses actes et donc de ses paroles
moi je condamne ce qu'a dit monsieur a
écrit je ne comprends pas que le cfcm le
garde comme représentant parce qu'ils
discréditent le cfcm
il discrédite aussi une partie je dirais
de la représentation à des musulmans en
france parce que c'est censé être un
modéré et moi je suis consterné et j'en
ai ras-le-bol qu'on ait de tels
représentants parce que il donne aussi
du crédit à tous ces petits cons qui
sont derrière leur compte twitter
anonyme et qui passent leur temps à
menacer harceler et à insulter
je le vis personnellement depuis des
années et j'en ai soit rien à ce sommet
est une zone que deux éléments soient
touchés c'est juste scandaleux et
monsieur écrit devrait devrait quand
même au moins être sanctionné par par le
cfcm un coup de gueule pour vous aurélie
gros également et cela concerne des
taxes sur une affiche de campagne du
secrétaire d'état à l'éducation gabriela
talent tout à fait vous avez pu admirer
en début d'année romain grau
député qui arrivent pour nazelle
récemment gabriela talent maintenant je
trouve que les violences contre les élus
augmente énormément et que c'était un
très mauvais signe pour notre démocratie
est clairement quand on voit qu'un grand
nombre d'élus ne veulent pas se
représenter plus de la moitié ne veulent
pas se représenter aux élections
municipales je pense que c'est un très
mauvais signe pour notre démocratie et
tous ceux qui sont mécontents et qui ont
des choses à dire au lieu d'aller faire
des taxes sur des affiches dans les
aurait mieux d'aller s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales et elle est dans les
urnes votez mousse latvala l'antisémite
les l'armée russe également racisme il
avait aujourd'hui dans les temps que
l'on connaît je crois que c'est quand
même assez ignoble de revenir à des
choses comme ça voilà je suis moi
personnellement scandalisé jeu
je voudrais dire tout mon soutien envers
ses élus de quelque parti qu'ils soient
parce qu'un élu ne mérite pas dans tous
les cas oui parce qu'ils expliquent les
gagnants se voir ce qu'il s'occupe de
ses idées c'est de s'occuper en tout cas
de sa population
qu'ils soient députés voilà c'est quand
même un engagement d'être élu
aucun élu ne mérite une telle violence
merci beaucoup ri gros merci lydia
guirous ce pour votre contribution à
cette émission merci beaucoup gailleton
du sausset et jean philippe tanguy
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france elle c'est la fin de deux pôles
it mag
restez avec nous à suivre l'information
[Musique]